hi there
reject nation I'm Greg and I'm John whoa
whoa whoa Greg and Jean are at it again
with watching an old trailer success for
a video game that Greg has beat on the
iPhone app not the actual console hey
hey that's a real game - all right
Batman Arkham origins
official trailer this is a cinematic
trailer and I have not seen this but I
believe I've seen snippets of it in like
compilations of certain things or you
know when people do like fan trailers
and they might take an image or two out
of I think you see one of our top reward
tiers is whatever video you request we
must definitely do them put up on the
youtubes that's from patreon by the way
and today comes from low-heat Banares
yay it's actually pronounced Mohit
Banerjee my bed are beautiful Indian man
from Canada
he's Indian right you are today
this one's directed by Tim Miller
anythings this probably helped a lot of
getting him the gig for that one comic
book movie Deadpool
I love the sound this is making he's
great you know trust Ian frame is great
yes he said it's based during Christmas
time so it fits it's a christmas for the
month it's christmas movies with
diehards a christmas movie now - i mean
he did say the game wasn't as good as
the trailer but hey you know what enough
chitchat that he's 15 through 16
hmm metropolis got ham City
Hey
[Applause]
snowing
Gotham in winter black masks get a
henchman voice
oh damn this is why Superman hates it
huh
[Music]
all right
all right I'm Enzo like you got
Deathstroke ditch
yeah I've seen everything like little
snippets
[Music]
I love these graphics yeah beautiful
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
come on bat oh yeah
Oh
[Music]
[Music]
and next time you're under that without
my wedding you and Rashad
that's smouldering log and all cool
[Music]
yes
yeah pre-ordered this yeah definitely
[Laughter]
that was bitchin man I really dug that a
lot I dig it
he's got Tim mr. surprise I never I
always thought that this was part of the
actual game whenever I saw snippets so I
never bought her and tried to find it I
didn't realize it was just the trailer
itself or maybe they're actually is
footage in here
good job Tim Miller this does make me
wish that we could get a live-action
Batman more along the lines of this
where you have like more of the grounded
villains like black mask Deathstroke we
do have a dead shot already in Suicide
Squad you know William Smith the
greatest youtuber of all time oh yeah
million subscribers if anything this
made me go yeah I wish Deathstroke was
the villain in the Matt Reeves movie
yeah yeah yeah because it's like he's
our like a perfect match for Batman in
terms of like he's tactical but he's
also got all the like crazy weaponry and
stuff like that that way they used him
like the choreography in this even
though it's just an animated video game
ad was actually pretty cool too like the
way falls off the top of the crates and
uses the staff to become like a beam to
shoot him back up again little things
like that would be so cool to see you
know like in an actual movie and this
also felt like a nice blend of you know
the more tactical grounded Batman from
the Nolan movies but also with a Gotham
City that feels like a comic-book Gotham
City this could have been what Ben
Affleck's Batman was in BBS and linked
up in some way to this type of territory
which would have been so excellent to
get but I'm just so sad that Affleck
it's probably out hello Todd Ness smile
yeah but yeah but just even having the
hint of like Deadshot in there to me
this is like the Batman movie I want to
see we always want to see like the
classic more classic villains like Joker
or relearn here but to have you know
villains who are much more of a lethal
threat in terms of the hand-to-hand like
black mask as an ultimate gangster but
and he can kind of fight but you know a
Deathstroke and Deadshot like if you
were to go up against them I think you'd
be pretty cool if you had you know Will
Smith's Deadshot go up against the
Batman in the
see you now that would also be pretty
sweet but in terms of this short film I
really like its aesthetic because it
kind of feels like you know the
Christmas time is sort of a yeah yeah
tales of like a murder on Christmas Day
or so yeah sort of has that level of
noir element to it while still being
very modern in terms of its a stylist
direction this is a pretty awesome short
and I wish I caught it before but it's
not I can watch it now with you guys
this is pretty sweet well I'm just a
simple aesthetic now I love Gotham and
snow yeah you know I kind of wish that
that would make its way back into a
Batman nuts as Batman Returns no and
Dark Knight Rises but yeah it gets
chilly and snows I guess you don't
remember it was definitely snowing in
the dark yeah it was definitely snowing
in the dark now a hunter process it's
not what I took away from that movie I
want a Batman movie the main impression
is the snow I just want to sit there
yeah the action was cool you know
detective fighter all that stuff but did
you see those landscapes man really
solving crime in a winter wonderland
I will though heat low it thanks so much
for requesting this buddy under the
short film that's quite inspirational in
your life and by the way though he makes
short films as well you should go check
out his youtube channel called another
view we are subscribed to his channel
you guys should subscribe as well if we
did a reaction one of his short films
called retreat which is a wonderfully
told horror film that was actually
perfectly inspired by the Dead Island
cinematic trailer that we covered last
month and so I guess what he likes to
request our video game trailers that are
better than the actual game themselves
let's keep up the consistency in that
department buddy hopefully we get a meet
up in person soon much love to you man
anyway you guys can subscribe to the
reject nation please click that
notification bell or ring it and check
us out on patreon we got weekly Q&A a TV
show reaction watch along as I just did
Gotham and today so actually watching
this was like I cannot see that Bruce
Wayne evolving into this and you guys
can